you dude s'excuse au centre aujourd'hui
sur fr un mario pour faire le deuxième
épisode
alors c'est une vidéo que je ne veux
absolument pas faire vous êtes nombreux
à vouloir donc je la fais c'est quoi ce
bordel ou de poursuivre par un fantôme
ça commence très très bien on a des
carapaces rouges
ça commence sans lui fait le truc qu'un
bateau à t'attend coup de tête coup de
tête violent coup de tête
quelle était la probabilité que je
retrouve sur cette carapace s'il vous
plaît dites là moi bordel
roos autres des piques c'est quoi les
manières mais quel est le délire de
faire à manger au oui why are you
running away mais ils sont sérieux alors
attendez on a la carapace
non l'autre allez on y retourne à
esquiver le trou découvre là qu'un
patron tumultueux office etc et le terme
probabilité que je retourne deux fois
sur ces carapaces dit là moi j'étais
javel aussi bon allez on y retourne
heureusement que les nuages derrière me
faut un smiley parce que sinon je pense
pas que je pourrais y arriver tout ce
mic pour tourner l'impression de tourner
au super jeu alors qu'en fait cet âge là
c'est vraiment un détail crucial de ce
jeu vidéo sur le web sainte
[ __ ] de jeu
et au retour de call me manque pour y
arriver et non et puis le trou le tout
cuisiné gouzi gouzi les csss alors je
les oublie toujours cela on est vilain
vilain garçon et fille d'un pic
ah oui
hamada sol et attendez c'est une blague
dead again
euh c'est pas faire c'est pas juste
laissez-nous vous envoyer sur le
prochain niveau quoi les mecs points
niveau impossible à finir spécialement
pour te faire craquer ils te mettre dans
un état pas possible on se fout de notre
gueule sur le cul ce qui n'est pas
possible aaa
retournons ci est ce qu'il y a pas moyen
d'aller enfin adéens définitivement non
définitivement en dessous ah bon il va
mettre des trous et des pics à vendre
exergue ne suffit pas à oignies voie
possible
c'est une question sérieuse
est il possible de réussir ce niveau
peut-être après j'ai une idée c'était la
meilleure idée du monde est alors donné
des noms je suis preneur
bon on fait la technique depuis tout à
l'heure on y va on y va
oh c'est bon les nuages souri à la
plateforme ne sais pas à quoi elle sert
mais elle est pourtant là pour te mettre
la pression tout s'effondre vous avez
jeté un top
vous imaginez vous un monde où tout
s'effondre comme ça dont savent aussi on
attend que la cap a trouvé un petit pas
en arrière comme ça on y va c'est une
carapace qui marche les troupes se fout
de notre gueule
ok ok je m'en vais non ils n'aiment pas
la technique franco toile et on est
retourné au tournoi messieurs dames
c'est la kermesse de mari comment vous
dire je ne cache est passé un cap
allez allez ça serait bien qu'on
réussisse peut-être un jour à faire un
niveau en vidéo allez on y va on y va
pendant ce temps le cube alpiq yes on
sait pas m
ah bah oui oh tu es vraiment nuls en
trois mois vous pouvez voter pour
quelqu'un d'autre
non cette direction en propose que et
éventuellement en se masturbant temps de
jouer je sais que ça pourrait marcher
blacksad pour la pêche me lave les mains
mario s'est envolé c'est normal tout va
bien on a fini le niveau c'est le plus
beau jour